hey I mean they have it's a totally
different model I mean that that their
model is is being big and you know being
able to deliver certain things that we
can't necessarily lover we we work with
best people in the world I mean we have
better creatives I think we're much more
easily adapt you know we can adapt to
things much more easily and we don't
have to we don't have to do a lot of the
things and were you saying earlier how
do you motivate people we don't have to
take on massive really not that fun
projects to pay for hundreds and
hundreds of people we can be a little
more picky with the stuff that we do and
on our model specifically is it sort of
borrowed a little bit I guess through my
film work that were you know you know
how a film studio would have you know
they have a layer of kind of very
experienced executives and then they
have a bunch of sort of more
administrative people but the people in
the middle it doesn't make sense to have
you know have a bunch of directors and
cinematographers and gaffers on staff
because you know you staff as you as you
go and similarly if we have you know if
we have an ad agency if you have an art
director and you have a bunch of people
sitting around you you only use them and
so we we use a lot of freelancers and I
mean New York is best for that I means
there's so many amazingly talented
people that you can reuse it for a
project specifically
so I think
you